اخر المعلومات ما اكدته لنا مصادر عسكريه
عليمه بان الجيش السوداني او قوات المسلحه
السودانيه بسطت سيطرتها بالكامل على مطار
مروي الدولي وعلى قاعده مروي العسكريه
السودانيه الجيش السوداني نؤكد بانه بسط
سيطرته كامله على مطار مروي الدولي وعلى
قاعده مروي العملياتيه الجويه المصادر
ايضا اكدت بان العمليه العسكريه التي تمت
خلال الساعات الماضيه اسفر عنها اشتباكات
عنيفه هذه الاشتباكات اضطرت معها حسب
المعلومات قوات الدعم السريع
لمغادره القاعده ولمغادره المطار يبدو ان
قوات السودانيه افسحت المجال او اعطت مهله
لهذه القوات ولكن اشتدت عمليه الحصار داخل
هذه القاعده عليه فان قوات الدعم السريعه
الان هي خارج حدود مطار مروي الدولي ايضا
المعل التي بحوزتنا الان بان قوات الدعم
السريع عندما غادرت هذه
القاعده والمطار اصطحبت معها نحو 27 من
افراد القوه المصريه التي تتبع للجيش
المصري وتتبع للقوات الجويه السودانيه اي
هذا يعني ان القوه المصريه التابعه للجيش
السوداني هي الان خارج القاعده ولكنها
بمعيه قوات الدعم السريعه ايضا المعلومات
تؤكد بان الجيش السوداني او القوات
المسلحه السودانيه استطاعت ان تستحوذ على
السيارات واهليات من داخل المطار التابعه
لقوات الدعم السريع وايضا تمكنت من الحصول
على سياره تعرف بسياره السيطره
تستخدم للتنسيق وللاتصالات وقد اديرت بها
العمليه العسكريه كما ان نحو 47 الى 50
فرد من افراد قوات الدعم السريع هم الان
يوصفون كاسرى بحصبه توصيف العسكري في يد
القوات المسلحه السودانيه هنا في مدينه
مروي هذه ابرز التحديثات وابرز المعلومات
التي يمكن ان تصدر من مروي لتعطي اشارات
جديده حول مسار هذه العمليه العسكريه التي
بدات يوم الامس في مروي لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات